bonjour bienvenue dans un entretien sur
france 24 notre invité aujourd'hui et le
maire d'odessa guennadi truca nov il est
avec nous depuis la troisième ville
d'ukraine qui est aussi un port
stratégique sur les bords de la mer
noire merci beaucoup monsieur le maire
d'après le président zelensky un assaut
aux russes sur odessa être imminent
quelle est la situation dans votre ville
bonjour
je suis ravi de pouvoir m'exprimer
devant vous et de vous parler de la
situation à odessa
est-ce que la situation est calme ou est
ce que on est au bord d'un assaut
militaire russe
aujourd'hui la situation est calme
relativement calme à odessa il y à des
combats à côté de la ville de mes
collègues c'est à cent kilomètres
d'odessa ainsi hier
la banlieue et les banlieues de la ville
ont été bombardés par des roquettes
les frappes ont été effectuées non pas
sur les zones résidentielles mais sur
des sites déjà abîmée il y à des
tentatives de bombardements il ya des
tentatives de mener des tirs précis nous
voyons des drones à proximité de la
ville pour des raisons de renseignement
est-ce que donc vous craignez que dans
les jours qui viennent il y est un
assaut russe sur votre ville monsieur le
maire
nous sommes très la ville est prête
ils sont prêts à repousser si jamais il
y en a ça
dans la mer noire il y à des navires
russes
cela dit pendant tout ce temps là nous
avons renforcé notre ville
les forces armées les ukrainiennes
effectivement renforcer toute la ville
nous avons
effectivement renforcer nos défenses
nous avons mines et les plages
nous avons monté et lever les barricades
et déployer des points pour pouvoir
repousser l'ennemi est ce que vous avez
à odessa ou autour des moyens de défense
anti aérien
oui en effet nous avons les moyens de
défense anti aérienne je ne pourrais pas
vous dévoiler plus d'informations vous
ne comprenez bien est-ce que donc vous
craignez que la sauce soit un assaut
aérien une invasion par la mer où une
attaque terrestre
conformément la tactique militaire nous
pensons
l'attaquent proviendra de la mer
parce que il y a une formation de
navires militaires dans la mer noire de
neuf à onze navires de débarquement
et en cas d'invasion elles atterrissent
au ras
mais nous nous attendons également à des
bombardements d'artillerie de masse
et donc les gnons que nos défenses anti
aériennes seront impactés est ce que
vous craignez aussi parce que odessa et
voisine de la moldavie il ya une région
en moldavie qu'on connaît comme la
transnistrie où il ya évidemment des
soldats russes stationnées depuis
longtemps est ce que vous craignez que
l'attak puisse aussi venir de ce côté là
12 heures chers amis
craindre
c'est un mot effectivement qui que nous
connaissons nous avons peur pour nos
enfants mais nous n'avons pas peur pour
nous nous voulons protéger nos terres en
ce qui concerne la transition
nous savons que les troupes russes sont
déployés n'a pas
nous avons et les informations sur leur
armement
évidemment il se peut qu'il y ait une
attaque de la part de la transnistrie
également de ce côté là aussi
les forces armées ukrainiennes sont au
courant et il faut face à cela alors en
ce qui concerne la protection de la
population civile est ce que il y as
assez d'abris pour la population en cas
d' attaques russes comme cela semble se
dessiner
je suis élu élu maire de la ville il y a
huit ans l'année 2014 2015 ses amis fut
très compliqué il y a eu des
éclosion nous avons mis tout ce temps là
pour pouvoir mettre sur pied une des
abris je dois dire qu'aujourd'hui ils
sont opérationnels
la population sait où se trouvent ces
abris à proximité
nous avons également des parkings soit
disant ce sont des sites de problèmes de
production
à 1000 euros également des systèmes d'
alerte de la population c'est très
important hier nous avons entendu je le
signale d' alerte et les civils ont pu
regagner ses parkings etc abri à temps
pour une montée aujourd'hui nous
renforçons kilos d'essence nous avons
des stocks de produits alimentaires
parce que en cas d'agression il faut une
qu'il ya un siège l'une des tactiques
nous pensons donc qu'il est absolument
important d'avoir un stock de
médicaments et de produits alimentaires
aujourd'hui l'aide
de la france et l'aide des pays de
l'occident
arrive arrive à odessa y compris les
produits alimentaires que dites vous à
votre population notamment aux femmes et
aux enfants vous les encourager à
quitter odessa au plus vite et est ce
que c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment
vous avez parlé des femmes et je dois
dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est la fête
internationale des femmes je leur
souhaite la bonne fête internationale de
femmes à aux femmes de dessin aux femmes
françaises p santé
amour tout cela nous le souhaitons nous
sommes des hommes et nous sommes prêts à
défendre de familles et nos enfants bien
sûr que nous essayons
de faire tout pour que nos femmes et nos
enfants nous voient pas ces atrocités
parce que ça risque de les traumatiser
pour des années à venir
ils savent déjà ce que c'est l'alertent
entier
bombardements aériens
les femmes soeurs ne filles
sont impactés mais bien sûr elle elle
refuse de quitter la ville de partir
elle veut le rester avec à nos côtés
mais nous essayons de faire tout pour
pouvoir
les mettre en sécurité
et pour les protéger contre la guerre
est ce que vous craignez vous devez
quand même suivre ce qui se passe
ailleurs notamment à kharkiv la deuxième
ville du pays qui est bombardé il ya
beaucoup de cibles civiles qui sont
touchées on sait à quel point odessa est
stratégique parce que si les russes
prennent odessa après avoir pris
personne après avoir assiégé marioupol
cela fermerait l'accès de l'ukraine à la
mer est ce que vous craignez que étant
donné cet objectif stratégique les
russes soient prêts à tout y compris à
raser odessa
à dire ça
la ville d'odessa c'est une ville
ayrault ce n'est pas une simple ville
vous c'est la capitale du sud 2 le
prennent le pense on ne le croyons c'est
un symbole de le cren
c'est le symbole de la mer noire il est
très important pour nous c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous défendrons sans
fléchir la ville d'odessa
et je pense que grâce au soutien du
monde entier grâce au soutien européen
nous devons trouver tous les moyens tout
pour arrêter cette guerre atroce c'est à
nous de le faire aujourd'hui je tiens à
remercier chien
tous les diplomates le maire de la ville
de marseille
qui est en contact avec nous je tiens à
remercier le gouvernement
français pour leur soutien c'est très
important encore dans la ville besoin de
dessin vous savez
je n'arrive même pas à imaginer
que le dessin codesa puisse ne pas
exister je suis né à odessa j'ai
travaillé au dessin j'ai deux filles
deux petits fils
nous n'avons à rien à part au dessin
c'est notre vie et nous allons rester
jusqu'au bout est ce que vous craignez
que vladimir poutine soit prêt à
attaquer au dessin à la détruire parce
que il veut absolument gagner est ce que
vous avez peur de ça monsieur le maire
vous avez
vous savez
je vais vous dire ainsi
jusqu'à maintenant je pouvais même pas
imaginer
que kharkiv
allait être écrasés ou effacer je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas la réponse
si président poutine est prêt ou pas à
le faire je m'attendais même pas à cette
action à cette ovation de la part de la
russie contre le kremlin vous comprenez
les mondes de l'adn fx dénazification
ça n'a rien à voir avec la russie
l'ukraine n'est pas en piste des nazis
nous chérissons la mémoire des héros de
la seconde guerre mondiale nous
chérissons l'histoire club la ville de
kharkiv
est une ville russophone à 80% la ville
tire ni et à 70% ville
la ville de tyr nagui est en train
d'être écrasés effacé de la face de la
terre je ne pourrai donc pas vous dire
si il est prêt ou non pas prêt je ne
sais pas quelles sont leur état d'esprit
juste pour conclure monsieur le maire
vous vous êtes un ancien militaire
j'imagine que vous continuez à porter
une arme surtout en ces temps
de bataille militaire est ce que vous
êtes prêts à rester dans votre ville et
vous y battre jusqu'à la fin ou est-ce
que vous pensez que il va falloir à un
moment peut-être partir si la sauce
confiant
je n'ai pas le droit moral
d'abandonner ma ville en tant que
résidents de cette ville en tant que
maire de donner ça je resterai je
resterai à au dessin jusqu'au bout et je
ne quitterai pas ma ville bienne a dit
rocha nov merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
de répondre aux questions de france 24
depuis
odessa ce port sur la mer noire qui vit
des heures sombres merci à vous d'avoir
suivi cette interview sur nos antennes
restez-y pour plus d'informations
[Musique]